[Música]
apenas tienen 10 años pero aquí están
con sus caballos galopando a través de
la arena senegalesa para estos niños
los caballos representan la esperanza de
un futuro mejor
el entrenamiento comienza todos los días
al amanecer
babakar tiene 13 años este es su primer
año de entrenamiento cuando montó a
caballo soy feliz creo que será más
fácil para mí tener una buena vida
convirtiéndome en un jinete que siendo
la escuela un día tendré éxito y ayudaré
a mis padres
en senegal los jinetes ganan en promedio
el doble del salario de un funcionario y
el desempleo juvenil alcanza niveles muy
altos
[Música]
y dejará
así que aquellos que logran entrar no lo
dudo mucho
[Música]
babakar solía venir mucho aquí con su
hermano así es como empezó a montar a
caballo un día le dije déjalo en
nuestras manos tiene potencial
los niños se entrenan en este criadero
de caballos en los suburbios de dakar
son elegidos después de cumplir diez
años y debe empezar menos de 40 kilos el
entrenamiento es gratuito y a los niños
se les da techo y comida sin embargo no
hay escuela es una vida de adultos
cuando comienza el día le doy comida y
agua a los caballos
después de eso limpio los
compartimientos vamos a entrenar luego
los dejó descansar hasta la noche y
después vuelvo a limpiar los
compartimientos a pesar de las duras
condiciones y el gran riesgo de
accidentes
el propietario del criadero de caballos
recibe decenas de solicitudes la gente
aquí ve muchas carreras de caballos
europeas son un modelo e inspiran a la
gente aquí actualmente hay 20 niños
inscritos aquí pero me vio obligado a
rechazar a otros 30
hay mucho entusiasmo definitivamente
para sentir este entusiasmo nos
dirigimos al hipódromo la verdad mi
asignación bienvenida h
el día de carreras y para babacar es tan
solo la segunda hasta ahora vine con mis
amigos aquí los niños tratan de
enfrentarse a los adultos experimentados
como mohamed gadiaga uno de los mejores
jinetes del país
babakar sin embargo no está impresionado
toca su amuleto de la suerte y hace una
llamada importante
era mi mamá me dijo que rezará antes de
la carrera suenan los tambores es hora
de que todo sencilla en sus caballos y
compitan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los mejores jinetes toman la delantera
rápidamente
[Música]
d
cómo
mohamed ya vuelve a ganar pero para
bajar la carrera fue una gran decepción
al principio iba de segundo luego un
caballo se adelantó de bloqueo de la
curva y todos me adelantaron
yo gane hoy pero mañana será tu turno
todo ese trabajo duro que me trajo aquí
tú también tienes que hacerlo
cree en ti cree en este trabajo y lo
lograrás
es un largo camino para convertirse en
campeón
[Música]
pero cada carrera despierta pasiones y
crean nuevas ilusiones de convertirse
algún día en el número uno